NARRATOR: The following content
is provided under a
Creative Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: OK, so I guess
we're ready to start.
Clearly, you can talk to
us about the exams
later if you want to.
And we will both be around after
class for a bit-- or
I'll be around after
class for a bit and
regular office hours.
Wanted to finish talking about
[INAUDIBLE] state Markov
change today and go on to talk
about Markov processes.
And the first thing we want
to talk about is what does
reversibility mean.
I think reversibility is one
of these very, very tricky
concepts that you think you
understand about five times,
and then you realize you
don't understand
it about five times.
And hopefully by the sixth time,
and we will see at about
six times, so hopefully by the
end of the term, it will look
almost obvious to you.
And then, we're going to talk
about branching processes.
I said and what got passed out
to you that I'd be talking
about round robin and
processor sharing.
I decided not to do that.
It was too much complexity for
this part of the course.
I will talk about it just
for a few minutes.
And then we'll go into
Markov processes.
And we will see most of the
things we saw in Markov change
again but in a different context
and in a slightly more
complicated context.
So for any Markov chain, we
have these equations.
Typically, you just state the
equation of the probability of
X sub n plus 1 given all the
previous terms is equal to
probability of Xn n
plus 1 given Xn.
It's an easy extension
to write it this way.
The probability of lots of
things in the future given
everything in the past is equal
to lots of things in the
future just given the most
recent thing in the past.
So what we did last time was to
say let's let A plus be any
function of all of these things
here, and let's A minus
be any function of all of these
things here except for X
sub n, namely X sub n
minus 1 down to X0.
And then what this says more
generally is the probability
of all these future things
condition on Xn, and all the
past things is equal to
probability of the future
given just Xn.
Then, we wrote that by
multiplying by the probability
of A minus given Xn.
And you can write it in this
nice symmetric form here.
I'm hoping that these two laser
pointers, one of them
will keep working.
And as soon as you write it in
this symmetric form, it's
clear that you can again turn
it around and write in the
past given the present and the
future is equal to the past
given the present.
So this formula really is
the most symmetric form
[? for it ?] and it really shows
the symmetry of past
future, at least as far as
Markov chains are concerned.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: I don't understand
[INAUDIBLE]
write that down though.
I feel like I'm missing
a step.
For example, let's say I
[INAUDIBLE], I can't infer
where I came from?
PROFESSOR: No, that's
not what this says.
I mean all it says is a
probabilistic statement.
It says everything you can say
about X sub n plus 1 which was
the first way we stated.
Everything you know about X sub
n plus 1, you can find out
by just looking at X sub n.
And knowing the things before
that doesn't help you at all.
When you write it out a Markov
chain in terms of a graph, you
can see this because you see
transitions going from one
state to the next state.
And you don't remember
what the past is.
The only part of the past
you remember is
just that last state.
It look you're still puzzled.
So it's not how it's saying we
can't tell anything about the
past and the future.
In fact, if you don't condition
on X sub n, this
stuff back here has a great
deal to do with
the stuff up here.
I mean it's only when you do
this conditioning, it is
saying that the conditioning
at the present is the only
linkage you have between
past and future.
If you know where you are now,
you don't have to know
anything about the past and know
what's going to happen in
the future.
That's not the way life is.
I mean life is not
a Markov chain.
It's just the way these
Markov chains are.
But this very symmetric
statement says that as far as
Markov chains are concerned,
past and future look the same.
And that's the idea that we're
trying to use when we get into
reversibility.
This isn't saying anything about
reversibility, yet this
is just giving a general
property that
Markov chains have.
And when you write this out,
it says the probability of
this past state given Xn and
everything in the future is
equal to the probability of the
past state given X sub n.
So this is really the Markov
condition running from future
down to past.
And it's saying that if you
want to evaluate these
probabilities of where you were
given anything now and
further on, or put it in a more
sensible way, if you know
everything over the past year,
and from knowing everything
over the past year, you want
to decide what can you tell
about what happens the year
before, what it's saying is
the probability of what happened
the year before is
statistically a function only
on the last day on the first
day of this year that you're
conditioning on.
So Markov condition works
in both directions.
You need to study state and
forward change to be there in
order to have homogeneity
in a backward chain.
In other words, usually, we
define a Markov chain by
starting off at time zero and
then evolving from there.
So when you go backwards, that
fact that you started at time
zero and said something about
time zero destroys the
symmetry between past
and feature.
But if you start off in steady
state, then everything is as
it should be.
So if you have a
positive-recurrent Markov
chain in steady state, it
can't be in steady state
unless it's positive-recurrent,
because
otherwise, you can't evaluate
the steady-state
probabilities.
The steady-state probabilities
don't exist.
And the backward probabilities
are probability that X sub n
minus 1 equals j given that
X sub n equals i is the
transition probability from i
to j times the steade-state
probability pi sub
j over pi sub y.
This looks more sensible if you
bring the pi sub i over
there, pi sub i times
probability of Xn minus 1
equals j given Xn equals i is
really the probability of Xn
equals i and Xn minus
1 equals j.
So what this statement is really
saying is it's pi i
times the probability of Xn
minus one equals j given Xn
equals i is really the
probability of being in state
j at time n minus 1 and state
i at time [? n. ?]
And we're just writing that
in two different ways.
It's the base law way of
writing things in two
different ways.
If we define this backward
probability, which we said you
can find by base law if you
want to work at it, if we
define this to be the backward
transition probability, p sub
ij star, in other words, p sub
ij star is in this world where
things are moving backwards, it
corresponds to p sub j in
the world where things
are moving forward.
P sub ij star is then the
probability of being in state
j at the next time back given
that you're in state i at this
time if you're in state
I at the present.
In other words, if you're
visualizing moving from future
time back to backward time,
that's what your Markov chain
is doing now.
These star transition
probabilities are the
probabilities of moving
backward by one step,
conditional going where you were
at time n, where you're
going to be at time n minus
1, if you will.
As I said, these things are much
easier to deal with if
you view them on a line, and you
have a right moving chain
which is what we usually think
of as the chain moving from
past to future.
And then you have a left moving
chain, which is what
you view as moving from
future down to past.
OK, we define a chain as
reversible if these backward
probabilities are equal to
the forward transition
probabilities.
So if a chain is reversible,
it's says that pi I times P
sub ij, this is the probability
that you are at a
time n minus 1, you were in
state I, and then you
move to state j.
So it's the probability of
being in one state at one
time, the next state
at the next time.
It's the probability that Xn
minus 1 and Xn are ij.
And this probability here is--
this equation is moving
forward in time.
So this equation here is the
probability that you were in
state j, and you move
to state i.
So what we're saying is the
probability of being in i
moving to j is the same as the
probability of being in j and
moving to i.
It's the condition you have
on any birth-death chain.
We said that on any birth-death
chain, the
fraction of transitions from i
to j has to be equal to the
total number of transitions
from j to i.
It's not that the probability
of moving up given i is the
same as that of moving back.
That's not what it's saying.
It's saying that the probability
of having a
transition over time
is pi i times Pij.
Reversibility says that you make
as many up transitions
over time as you make down
transitions over the
same pair of states.
I think that's the simplest
way to state the idea of
reversibility.
The fraction of time that you
move from state i to state j
is the same as the fraction of
time in which you move from
state j to state i.
It's what always happens on a
birth-death chain, because
every time you go up, if you
ever get back to the lower
part of the chain, you have to
move back over that same path.
You can easily visualize other
situations where you have the
same condition if you have
enough symmetry between the
various probabilities
involved.
But the simplest way is
to have this sort of--
well, not only the simplest, but
also the most common way
is to have a birth-death
chain.
OK, so this leads us to
the statement, all
positive-recurrent birth-death
chains are reversible, and
that's the theorem.
Now the question is what
do you do with that?
Let's have a more general
example than
a birth-death chain.
Suppose the non-zero
transition of a
positive-recurrent Markov
chain form a tree.
Before we had the states going
on a line, and from each state
to the next state, there were
transition probabilities, you
could only go up or
down on this line.
What I'm saying now is if you
make a tree you have the same
sort of condition that you had
before if the transitions on
the states look like a tree.
So these are the only
transitions that exist in this
Markov chain.
These are the states here.
Again, you have this
condition.
The only way to get from this
state out to this state is to
move through here so that the
number of transitions that go
from here to there must be
within one of a number of
transitions that go from
here back to there.
So you have this reversibility
condition again on any tree.
And these birth-death chains
are just very, very skinny
trees where everything is
laid out on a line.
But this is the more
general case.
And you'll see cases of
this as we move along.
The following theorem is one of
these things that you use
all the time in solving
problems.
And it's extraordinarily
useful.
It says for a Markov chain with
transition probabilities
P sub ij, if a set of numbers pi
sub i exists so that all of
them are positive,
they sum to one.
If you can find such a set of
numbers, and if they satisfy
this equation here, then you
know that the chain is
reversible, and you know that
those numbers are the
steady-state probability.
So you get everything at once.
It's sort of like a
guessing theorem.
And I usually call it a guessing
theorem, because
starting out, it's not obvious
that these equations have to
be satisfied.
They're only satisfied if you
have a chain which is
reversible.
But if you can find a solution
to these equations, then, in
fact, you know it's reversible,
and you know you
found steady--state
probabilities.
It's a whole lot easier to solve
this equation usually
than to solve the usual
equation we have for
steady-state probabilities.
But the proof of the theorem--
I just restated the theorem
here, leaving out all of the
boiler plate .
If we take this equation for
fixed j, and we sum over I,
what happens?
When you sum over i over on
this side, you get the sum
over i of pi sub i P sub ij.
When you sum over i on this
side, you get pi sub j,
because when you sum P sub ji
over i, you have to get one.
When you're in state j, you
have to go someplace.
And you can only go one place,
each with different
probabilities.
So that gives you the usual
steady-state conditions.
If you can solve those steady
state conditions, then you
know from what we did before
that the chain is
positive-recurrent.
You know there are steady-state
probabilities.
You know there's probabilities
are all greater than zero.
So if there's any solution to
these steady-state equations,
then you know the chain has
to be positive-recurrent.
And you know it has to be
reversible in this case.
OK, here are a bunch of sanity
checks for reversibility.
In other words, if you're going
to guess at something
that's reversible and try to
solve these equations, you
might as well do a sanity
check first.
The simplest and most useful
sanity check is if you want it
be reversible, and there's a
transition from i to j, then
there has to be a transition
from j to I also.
Mainly the number of transitions
going from i to j
has to be the same over the
long term to number of
transitions going from j to I.
If there's a zero transition
probability one way and not
the other way, you can't
satisfy that equation.
If the chain is periodic, the
period has to be too.
Why is that?
Well, it's a long proof
in the notes.
And if you write everything down
in algebra, it looks a
little long.
If you just think about it,
it's a lot shorter.
If you're going around on a
cycle of, say, link three, if
the chain is periodic, and it's
periodic with some period
others than two, then you know
that the set of states has to
partition into a
set of subsets.
And you have to move from one
subset, to the next subset, to
the next subset, and so forth.
When you go backwards, you're
moving around that cycle in
the opposite direction.
Now, the only way that moving
around a cycle one way and
moving around it the other way
works out is when the cycle
only has two states
[? set in, ?]
because then you're
moving, and you're
moving right back again.
OK, so the period has to be
two if it's periodic.
If there's any set of
transitions i to j, j to k,
and k to I, namely if you can
move around this way with some
probability, then the
probability of moving back
again has to be the
same thing.
And that's what this
is saying.
This is moving around this cycle
of length three one way.
This is the forward
probabilities for moving
around a cycle, the opposite way
and to have reversibility.
The probability of going one way
has to be the same as the
probability going
the other way.
Now, that sounds peculiar, and
it gives me a good excuse to
point out one of the main things
that's going on here.
When you say something is
reversible, it doesn't usually
mean that P sub ij is
equal to P sub ji.
What it means is that
pi sub I times Pij
equals pi j times Pji.
Namely, the fraction of
transitions here is the same
as the fraction of
transitions here.
Why is it that here I'm only
using the probabilities, and
I'm not saying anything about
the initial probability?
It's because both of these
cycles start with state i.
So what you really want to do
is say pi I times Pij times
Pjk times Pki is the same as
pi i times [INAUDIBLE]
And then you cancel
out the pi.
So when you have a cycle, you
don't need that initial
steady-state probability
in there.
There's a nice generalization
of the guessing theorem to
non-reversible change and that
generalization and it's proved
the same way that
this is proved.
If you can find a set of
transition probabilities, P
sub ij star, and to be a set of
transition probabilities,
they have to be non-negative.
When you sum this over j,
you have to get one.
That's what you need to have
a set of transition
probabilities.
Then, all you need is pi sub i
times P sub ij is equal to pi
j times P sub ji star.
In other words, when you look
at this backward transition
probability for an arbitrary
Markov chain which is
positive-recurrent, this
has to equal this.
This is one of the conditions
that you
have on a Markov chain.
The interesting thing here
is this is enough.
If you can guess a set of
backward transition
probabilities to satisfy this
equation for all i and j, then
you know you must have a set of
steady-state probabilities
where the steady-state
probabilities are [INAUDIBLE].
And the way to prove this
is the same as before.
Namely, you sum this over j.
And when you sum this over
j, you get the backward
transition probability.
So I'm not going to prove it.
I mean the proof is in the
notes, and it's really the
same proof as we went
through before.
And incidentally, if you read
the section on round robin,
you will find the key to finding
out what's going on
there is, in fact,
that theorem.
It's that way of solving for
what the steady-state
probabilities have to be.
While I'm at it, let me pause
for just a second, because
we're not going to go through
that section on round robin.
Let me talk about what it is,
what processor sharing is, and
why that result is
pretty important.
If you're at all
interested in--
well, let's see.
First pack of communication
is something important.
Second, computer systems of
all types is important.
There was an enormous transition
probably 20 years
ago from computer systems
solving one job at a time, and
then it went to the system
of solving many jobs
concurrently.
It would work a little bit on
one job, a little bit in
another, a little bit in
another, and so forth.
And it turns out to be a very
good idea for doing that.
Or if you're interested in
killing systems, what happens
if you have a killing system--
suppose it's a GG1 queue.
So you have a different service
time for each customer.
Or let's make it an MG1 queue.
Makes the argument cleaner.
Different customers have
different service times.
We've seen that in an MG1 queue,
everybody can be held
up by one slow customer.
And if the customers have an
enormously, widely varied
service time, some of them have
required enormously long
service time, that causes an
enormous amount of queuing.
What happens if you use
processor sharing, you have
one server.
And it's simultaneously
allocating service to every
customer which is in queue.
So it takes a service
capability, and it splits it
up end-wise.
And when you talk about
processor sharing, you assume
that there's no overhead for
doing the splitting.
And if there's no overhead for
doing the splitting, you can
see intuitively what happens.
The customers that don't need
much service are going to be
held up a little bit by these
customers who require enormous
amounts of service,
but not too much.
Because this customer that
requires enormous service is
getting the same rate of
service as you are.
If that customer requires 100
hours of service, and you only
require one second of service,
you're going to get out very
much faster than they do.
What happens when you
analyze all of this?
It turns out that you've
turned the MG1
queue into an MM1 queue.
In other words, if you're doing
processor sharing, it
takes the same expected amount
of time for you to get out as
it would if all of the service
times were exponential.
Now, that is why people
went to time
sharing a long time ago.
Most of the arguments for it,
especially in the computer
science fraternity, were all
sorts of other things.
But there's this very
simple queuing
argument that led to that.
Unfortunately, it's a fairly
complicated queuing argument,
which is why we're not
going through it.
But it's a very important
argument.
Why, at the same time, did we
go to packet communication?
Well, there are all sorts of
reasons for going to packet
communication instead of
sending messages, long
messages, one at a time.
But one of them, and one of them
is very important, is the
same process of sharing
resell.
If you split things up into
small pieces, then what it
means is effectively things are
being served in a process
of sharing matter.
So again, you get this losing
the slow truck effect.
And everybody gets through
effectively in a
fair amount of time.
OK.
I probably said just the wrong
amount about that, so you
can't understand what
I was saying.
But I think if you read it,
you will get the idea of
what's going on.
OK.
Let's look at an
MM1 queue now.
An MM1 queue, you remember,
is a queue where you have
customers coming in.
In a [? Poisson ?] manner, the
interval between customers is
exponential.
That you couldn't model
for a lot of things.
The service time
is exponential.
And what we're going to do to
try to analyze this in terms
of mark of change, is to say
well, let's look at sampling
the state of the MM1 queue at
some very finely spaced
interval of time.
And we'll make the interval of
time, delta, so small that
there's a negligible probability
of having two
customers come in in
the same interval.
And so there's a negligible
probability of having a
customer come in and
a customer go
out in the same interval.
It's effectively the same
argument that we use to say
that a Poisson process is
effectively the same as a
Bernoulli process, if you make
the time interval the step
size for the Bernoulli process
very, very small, and the
probability of success
very, very small.
As you make that time interval
smaller and smaller, it goes
in to a Poisson process as we
showed a long time ago.
This is the same
argument here.
And what we get then is this
system, which now has a state.
And the state is the
number of customers
that are in the system.
As one customer is being served,
rest of the customers
are sitting in a queue.
The transitions over some very
small time, delta, there's a
probability lambda delta that
a new customer comes in.
So there's a transition
to the right.
There's a probability mu delta,
if there's a server
being served, that that service
gets finished in this
time delta.
And if you're in state zero,
then of course, you can get a
new arrival coming in,
but you can't get any
service being done.
So it's saying, as you're all
familiar with, you have this
system where any time there are
customers in the system,
they're getting served
at rate mu.
Mu has to be bigger
than lambda to
make this thing stable.
And you can see that
intuitively, I think.
And when you're in state
zero, then the
server isn't doing anything.
So the server is resting,
because the server is faster
than the arrival process.
And then the only thing that
can happen is a new arrival
comes in, and then the server
starts to work again, and
you're back in state 1.
So this is just a time sampled
version of the MM1 queue.
And if you analyze this either
from the guessing theorem that
I just was talking about or the
general result for birth
death change that we talked
about last time.
You see that pi sub n minus 1
times lambda delta is equal to
pi sub n times mu delta.
The fraction of transitions
going up is equal to the
fraction of transitions
going down.
You take the steady state
probability of being in
state n minus 1.
You multiply it by the
probability of an up
transition.
And you get the same thing, as
you take the probability of
being in state by n and
multiply it by a down
transition.
If you define rho as being
lambda over mu, then what this
equation says is a steady state
probability of being in
state n is rho times the steady
state probability of
being in a state n minus 1.
This is the same as the general
birth death result,
except that rho is a constant
overall state
rather than state 1.
Pi sub n is then equal to a
rho sub n times pi zero.
And pi sub n is then equal
to, if you re-curse on
this, you get this.
Then you use the condition that
the pi sub i's have to
add up to 1.
And you get pi sub n has to
be equal to 1 minus rho
times rho to the n.
OK.
This is all very simple
and straightforward.
What's curious about
this is it doesn't
depend on delta at all.
You can make delta anything
you want to.
And we know that if we shrink
delta enough, it's going to
look very much like
an MM1 queue.
But it looks like an MM1 queue
no matter what delta is.
Just so long as lambda plus mu
times delta is less than or
equal to 1.
You don't want transition
probabilities to add up to
more than 1.
And you have these self loops
here which take up the slack.
And we saw before that the
steady state probabilities
didn't have anything to do with
these self transitions.
And that will turn out to be
sort of useful later on.
So we get these nice
probabilities which are
independent of the time
increment that we're taking.
So we think that this is
probably pretty much operating
like an actual MM1 queue
would operate.
OK.
Now here's this diagram that I
showed you last time, and I
told you was going
to be confusing.
And I hope it's a little less
confusing at this point.
We've now talked about
reversibility.
We know what reversibility
means.
We know that we have
reversibility here.
And what's going on?
We have this diagram on the
top, which is the usual
diagram for the way that
an MM1 queue operates.
You start out in state zero.
The only thing that can happen
from state zero is at some
point you get an arrival.
So the arrival takes
you up there.
You have no more arrivals
for a while.
Some later time, you get
another arrival.
[INAUDIBLE]
So this is just the arrival
process here.
This is the number of arrivals
up until time T. The same
time, when you have arrivals,
eventually since the server is
working now, at some point
there can be a departure.
So we go over to here in
the sample sequence.
There's eventually a
departure there.
There's a departure there.
And then you're back in
state zero again.
You go along until there's
another arrival.
Corresponding to this sample
path of arrivals and
departures, we can say
what the state is.
The state is just the difference
between the
arrivals and the departures
for this sample path.
So the state here start
out at time 1.
x1 is equal to 0.
Then at time x2, suddenly
an arrival comes in.
x2 is equal to 1, x3 is equal to
1, x4 is equal to 1, x5 is
equal to 1.
Another arrival comes in.
So we have a queue of 1.
We have the server operating
on one customer.
Then in the sample path, we
suppose there's a departure.
And we suppose that
the second arrival
required hardly any service.
So there's a very fast
departure there.
Now, what we're going to do is
to look at what happens.
This is the picture that we
have for the Markov chain.
This with the picture we had
for the sample path of
arrivals and departures for what
we thought was the real
life thing that was going on.
We now have the state diagram.
And now what we're going
to do is say, let's
look at this backwards.
And since looking at it
backwards in time is
complicated, let's look at
it coming in this way.
So we have the state diagram,
and we try to figure out what,
going backwards, is going
on here from these state
transitions.
Well in going backwards, the
state is increasing by 1.
So that looks like something
that we would call an arrival.
Now why am I calling these
arrivals and departures?
It's because the probability of
any sample path along here
is going to be the same as a
backward sample path, the same
sample path, going backwards.
That's what we've already
established.
And the probabilities going
backwards are going to be the
same as the probabilities
going forward.
Since we can interpret this
going forward as arrivals
causing up transitions,
departures causing down
transitions, going backwards we
can say this is an arrival
in this backward going chain.
This is an arrival in a
backward going chain.
This is a departure in the
We go along here.
Finally, there's another
departure in the backward
going chain.
This state diagram--
with two of them, we
might make it.
Yes, OK.
The state diagram here
determines this diagram here.
If I tell you what this
is, you can draw this.
You can draw every up transition
as an arrival,
every down transition
as a departure.
So this diagram is specified
by this diagram.
This diagram is also specified
So this and this each
specify each other.
Now if we interpret this
as arrivals and this is
departures, and we have the
probabilities of an MM1 chain,
then we say the statistics of
these arrivals here are the
same as a Bernoulli process,
which is coming along the
other way and leading
to arrivals.
What that says is the departure
process here is a
Bernoulli process.
Now you really have to
wrap your head around
that a little bit.
Because we know that departures
only occur when
you're in states greater
than or equal to 1.
So what's going on?
When you're looking at it in
forward time, a departure can
only occur from a non-negative
state to some other state.
Namely from some non-negative
state to some smaller state.
Now, when I look at
it backwards in
time, what do I find?
I can be in state zero.
And there could have been
a departure which may--
if I'm in state zero at time
zero, and I say there was a
departure between n minus 1 and
n, that just says that the
state at time n minus
1 was equal to 1.
Not that the state at time
n was equal to 1.
Because I'm running along here
looking at these arrivals
going this way, departures
going this way.
When I'm in state zero,
I can get an arrival.
I can't when I'm in state 1.
If I were here, I couldn't
get a departure in the
next unit of time.
Because the state is
equal to zero.
But I can be coming from
a departure in
the previous state.
Because in the previous state,
the state was 1.
I mean, you really have
to say this to
yourself a dozen times.
And you have to reason
about it.
You have to look at the diagram,
read the notes, talk
to your friends about it.
And after you do all of
this, it will start to
make sense to you.
But I hope I'm at least making
it seem plausible to you.
So each sample path corresponds
to both a right
and left moving chain.
And each of them are MM1.
So we have Burke's theorem.
And Burke's theorem says given
an MM1 sample time Markov
chain in steady state, first,
the departure processes
Bernoulli at rate lambda.
OK.
Let me put it another way now.
When we look at it in the
customary way, we're looking
at things moving
upward in time.
We know there can't be
a departure when
you're in state zero.
That's because we're looking
at departures after
you're in time zero.
When we look at time coming in
backwards, we're not being
dependent on the state to the
left of that departure.
We're only dependent on the
state after the departure.
The state after departure
can be anything.
OK?
And therefore, after departure
you can be in
any state at all.
And therefore, you can always
have a departure, which leaves
you in state zero.
That's exactly what this
theorem is saying.
It's saying--
yes.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
departure process?
PROFESSOR: Well, a couple
of reasons.
If you had a Bernoulli process
and departure rate was mu,
over a long period of time,
you'll have more departures
than you have arrivals.
But the other, better reason is
that now you're amortizing
those departures
over all time.
And before, you were amortizing
them only over
times when the state of the
chain was greater than what?
The probability of the
state of the chain is
greater than 1 is rho.
And that's the difference
between lambda and mu.
OK?
It's not nice, but that's
the way it is.
Well actually, it is nice when
you're solving problems with
these things.
I mean some of you might have
noticed when you were looking
at the quiz problem dealing with
Poisson processes, that
it was very, very sticky to say
things about what happens
at some time in the
past, given what's
going on in the future.
Those are nasty problems
to deal with.
This makes those problems
very easy to deal with.
Because it's saying, if you go
backward in time, you reverse
the role of departures
and arrivals.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Can you explain that
one more time, why it's lambda
and not mu?
Just the last thing you
said [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: OK.
Last thing I said was that the
probability that the state is
bigger than zero is rho.
Because the probability of the
state is zero is 1 minus rho.
I mean that's not obvious, but
it's just the way it is.
So that if you're trying to
find the probability of a
departure and you don't know
what the state is, and you
just look in at any old time,
it's sort of like a random
incidence problem.
I mean, you're looking into this
process, and all you know
is you're in steady state.
And you don't know what
the state is.
I mean you can talk about
the earlier state.
You can't talk about--
I mean usually when we talk
about these Markov chains,
we're talking about state of
time n, transition from time n
to n plus 1.
And in that case, you can't have
a departure if you're in
state zero at time n.
Now the transition from time n
to n plus 1, if we're moving
the other way in time, we're
starting out at time n plus 1.
And we're starting out
at time n plus 1.
If you're in state zero there,
you can still be coming out of
a departure from time n.
I mean suppose at time n the
state is 1, and at time n plus
1 the state is zero.
That means there was
a departure between
n and n plus 1.
But when you're looking at it
from the right, what you see
is the state at time
n plus 1 is zero.
And there's a probability
of a departure.
And it's exactly the same as the
probability of a departure
given any other state.
OK?
If you're just doing this as
mathematicians, you could look
at these formulas and say
yes, I agree with that.
It's all very simple.
Since we're struggling here to
get some insight as to what's
going on and some
understanding of
it, it's very tricky.
Now, the other part of Burke's
theorem says the state at n
delta is independent of
departures prior to n delta.
And that seems even worse.
It says you're looking at
this Markov chain at
a particular time.
And you're saying the state of
it is independent of all those
departures which happened
before that.
That's really saying
something.
But if you use this
reversibility condition that
says, when you look at things
going from right to left,
arrivals become departures and
departures become arrivals.
Then that statement there is
exactly the same as saying the
state of a forward going chain
at time n is independent of
the arrivals that come
after time n.
Now, you all know
that to be true.
Because you're all used to
looking at these things moving
forward in time.
So whenever you see a statement
like that, just in
your head reverse time, or turn
your head around so that
right becomes left and
left becomes right.
And then departures become
arrivals and arrivals become
departures.
You can't do one without
the other.
You've got to do both
of them together.
OK.
So everything we know about the
MM1 sample time chain has
a corresponding statement with
time reversed and arrivals and
departure switched.
So it's not only Burke's
theorem.
I mean, you can write down
100 theorems now.
And they're all the same idea.
But the critical idea
is the question
that two of you asked.
And that is, why is the
departure rate going to be
lambda when you look at things
coming in backwards.?
And the answer again is that
it's lambda because we're not
conditioning it on knowing
what the prior state was.
And everything else you know
about these things, you always
condition things on
the prior state.
So now we're getting used
to conditioning them
on the later state.
OK.
Let's talk about branching
processes.
Branching processes have
nothing to do with
reversibility.
Again, these are just very
curious kinds of processes.
They have a lot to do with all
kinds of genetic kinds of
things, with lots of physics
kinds of experiments.
I don't think a branching
process corresponds very
closely to any one
of those things.
This is the same kind of
modeling issue that we come up
against all the time.
What we do is, we pick very,
very simple models to try to
understand one aspect of
a physical problem.
And if you try to ask for a
model that understands all
aspects of that physical
problem, you've got a model
that's too complicated to
say anything about.
But here's a model that says
if you believe that one
generation to the next, if the
only thing that's happening is
the individuals in one
generation are spawning
children or are spawning
whatever it is in that next
generation, and every individual
does this in an
independent way, then this is
what you have to live with.
I mean that's what the
mathematics says.
The model is no good, but
the mathematics is fine.
So the mathematics is we suppose
that x of n is the
state of the Markov chain at
time n, and the Markov chain
is described in the following
way. x of n, we think of as
being the number of elements in
generation n, and for each
element k, out of that x of n,
each element gives rise to a
number of new elements.
And the number of new elements
it gives rise to we
call it y sub kn.
The n at the end is for the
generation, the k is for the
particular element in
the case generation.
So y sub kn is the number of
offspring of the element k in
the n-th generation.
After the element in
the n-th generation
gives birth, it dies.
So it's kind of a cruel world,
but that's this particular
kind of model.
So the number of elements in
the n plus first generation
then, is the sum of the number
of offspring of the elements
in the n-th generation.
So it says x of n plus 1 is
equal to this y sub kn is the
number of offspring of element
k, and we sum that number of
offspring from 1 to
x of n, and that's
the equation we get.
The assumption we make is that
the non-negative integer
random variable y sub kn--
these random variables--
are independent, and identically
distributed over
both n and k.
There's this usual peculiar
problem that we have where
we're defining random variables
that might not
exist, but we should be
used to that by now.
I mean we just have the random
variable there and we pick
them out when we need
them is the best way
to think about that.
The initial generation x of 0
can be an arbitrary positive
random variable, but it's
usually taken to be y.
So you start out with one
element, and this thing goes
on from one generation
to the next.
It might all die out, or it
might continue, it might blow
up explosively, and we want
to find out which it does.
OK so here's the critical
equation.
Let's look at a couple of
examples of why sub kn is
deterministic, and equals 1, and
xn is equal to xn minus 1
is equal to x0 for all n greater
than or equal to 1.
So this example isn't
very interesting.
If y kn is equal to 2, then each
generation has twice as
many elements as the previous
generation.
Each element has
two offspring.
So you have something that looks
like a tree, which is
where the name branching process
comes from because
people think of these things
in terms of trees.
Each one element here two
offspring, two elements here,
and now if you visualize this
kind of chain, you can think
of this as being random.
So the perhaps in this
first generation
there are two offspring.
Perhaps this one has no
offspring the next time, so
this dies out.
This one has two offspring.
this one has no offspring,
this one has two.
Four, we're up to four.
And then all of them die out.
So we're talking about that kind
of process, which you can
visualize as a tree just
as easily as you can
visualize it this way.
Personally I find it easier
to do this as a tree.
Because that's personal
preference.
OK, so just talked about this
third kind of animal here.
If the probability of no
offspring is 1/2, and the
probability of twins is 1/2,
then xn, it's a rather
peculiar Markov chain.
It can grow explosively,
or it can die out.
Who would guess that it's going
to grow explosively on
the average?
And who would guess that it will
die out on the average?
I mean would anybody hazard to
make a guess that this will
die out with probability one?
Well it will, and we'll
see that today.
It can grow for quite a while,
but eventually it gets killed.
When we look at this process
now, the state
0 is trapping state.
The states 0 was always
a trapping state
for branching processes.
Because once you get to state
0, there's nothing to have
offspring anymore.
So state 0 is always
a trapping state.
But in other states you can have
rather explosive growth.
For this particular thing here
the even numbered states all
communicate, but there
are transient.
Each odd numbered state doesn't
communicate with any
other state.
As you see from this diagram
here, you're always dealing
with an even number
of states here.
Because each offspring
each element has
either two or 0 offspring.
So you're summing up a bunch of
even numbers, and you never
get anything odd, except this
initial state of one, which
you get out of right away.
OK so how do we analyze
these things?
We want to find the probability
for the general
case that the process
dies out.
So let's simplify our notation
a little bit.
We're going to let the pmf on
y-- we have a pmf on y because
y is an integer random
variable.
It's 0, or one, or
2, or so forth.
We'll call that p sub of k.
For the Markov chain namely
x0, x1, x2, and so forth,
we're going to let piece of ij
as usual, be the transition
probabilities in the
Markov chain.
And here it's very useful to
talk about the probability the
state j has reached on
or before step n,
starting from state i.
Remember we talked
about that--
I forget whether we
talked about last
time, or the time before--
but you can look it up,
and what it is.
The thing we derive for it is
the probability that you will
have touched state j in one of
the n previous tries starting
in state i.
It's p sub of ij.
That's the probability you reach
it right away so you're
successful.
And then for everything else you
might reach on the first
try, there's the probability
of going
to that state, initially.
So this is what happens
in the first trial.
And then there's the probability
you will have gone
from state k to state j, in
any one of the n minus 1
states after that.
So f ij of one is p ij.
And now what we're interested
in is we start with one
element, and we're interested
in the probability that it
dies out, before it explodes.
Or just the probability
it dies out.
So f sub 1,0 of n is the
probability starting in state
1 that you're going to reach
state 0 after n steps.
So it's p 0 plus sum here of
p sub k probability you go
immediately to state k, and now
here's the only hard thing
about this.
What I claim now is if we go
to state k, and state k we
have k elements in this
first generation.
Now what's the probability that
starting with k elements
we're going to be dead after
n minus 1 transitions?
Well to be dead after n minus
1 transitions every one of
these elements has to die out.
And they're independent.
Everything that's going on
from each element is
independent of everything
from each other element.
So the probability that this
first one dies out is f sub 1
0 over n minus 1 steps.
Probability the second
one dies out--
same thing. you take the
product of them.
So this is the probability that
we die out initially,
this sum from k equals
1 to infinity.
Is the probability that each of
the k descendants dies out
within time n minus 1.
We can take a p 0 into the sum
here, we sum from 0 up to
infinity, because s sub 1 0 to
the 0 is just equal to 1.
So we get this nice looking
formula here.
Let me do this quickly,
and then we'll go back
and talk about it.
Let's talk about
the z transform
of this birth process.
OK so we have this discrete
random variable y with pmf p
sub k h of z is the sum over k
if p sub k times z to the k.
It's just another kind of
transform, we have all kinds
of transforms in this course.
And this is one transform.
Given the state of a pmf, you
can define a function into z
in this way.
So f 1 0 of n is then equal to
h of f 1 0 of n minus 1.
It's amazing that all this mess
turns into something that
looks so simple.
So this will be the probability
that we will die
out by time end, if in fact we
know what the probability of
dying out at time
n minus 1 is.
So let's try to solve
this equation.
And it's not hard to solve
as you would think.
There's this z transform h of
z, h of z is given there.
What do I know about h of z?
I know its value, it's
z equal to 1.
Because it's z equal to 1, I'm
just summing p sub k times 1.
So h of 1 is equal to 1.
That's what this is in
both cases here.
What else do I know about it?
h of 0 is equal to p 0.
And if you take the second
derivative of this, you find
out immediately that the second
derivative is positive.
So this curve, this convex,
it goes like that.
As it's been drawn here.
The other thing we know is that
this derivative at 1 the
derivative of h of z is equal to
the sum of k times p to the
k, times k, times z
to the k minus 1.
I set z equal to 1,
and what is that?
It's the sum of pk times k.
So this derivative
here is y-bar.
In this case, I'm looking at a
case where y-bar is equal to
1, in this case, I'm looking
at a case where y-bar is
bigger than 1.
Everybody with me so far?
AUDIENCE: So what
is the y-bar?
PROFESSOR: y-bar is the expected
value of the random
variable y.
And the random variable y is the
number of offspring than
any one element will have.
The whole thing is defined
in terms of this y.
I mean it's the only thing that
I've given you except all
these independence conditions.
It's like the Poisson process.
There's only one element
in it, which is lambda.
A complicated process, but
it's defined in terms of
everything being independent
of everything else.
And that's the same thing kind
of thing we have here.
Well what I've drawn here is a
is a graphical way of finding
what f 1 0 of 1, f 1 0 of 2,
f 1 0 of 3 is and so forth.
And we start out with one
element here, and I want to
find h of f 1 0 of one
is h of f 1 0 of 0.
What is f 1 0 of 0?
It has to be 1.
So f 1 0 of n is just
equal to h of p 0.
So I trace from here, from p 0
over to this slope of one.
So this is p 0 down here, and
this point here is f 1 0 of 1,
at this point.
Starting here I go over to here,
and down here this is f
1 0 of one, as advertised.
I can move up to the curve
and I get h of 2.
h of f 1 0 h of z, where z
is equal to f 1 0 of 1.
And so forth along here.
I'm not going to spend a lot
of time explaining the
graphical procedure, because
this is something that you
look at on your own, and you
sort it out in two minutes,
and if I explained it, I mean
you'll be looking at it at a
different speed and
I'm explaining it
at, so it won't work.
But what happens is starting
out with sum p 0, you just
move along each of these points
are f 1 0 of 1, f 1 0
of 2, f 1 0 of 3, up to
f 1 0 of infinity.
This is the probability that
the process will die out
eventually.
So it's the point at which
h of z equals z.
That's the root of the equation,
We already know what that is
pretty much, because we know
that we're looking at it case
here where y-bar is
greater than 1.
So it means the slope here
is bigger than 1.
We have a convex curve which
starts on this side of this
line, that ends on the other
side of this line.
There's got to be a root
in the middle.
And there can only be one root,
so we eventually get to
that point.
And that's the probability
of dying out.
Now, over in this case,
y-bar is equal to 1.
Or I could look at a case y-bar
is less than 1, And what
happens then?
Keep moving around the same way,
I got up at that point,
and in fact h 1 0 of infinity
is equal to 1.
Which says the probability of
dying out is equal to 1.
These things that I'm
calculating here are in fact
the probability of dying out by
time 1, the probability of
dying out by time 2, and so
forth all the way up.
In here we start out on this
side of the curve.
We keep getting crunched in.
We wind up at that point, and in
this case, we keep getting
crunched up, and we wind
up at that point.
So the general behavior of these
branching processes is
so long as there's a possibility
of an element
having no children, there's a
possibility that the whole
process will die out.
But if the expected number of
offspring is greater than 1,
then that probability of dying
out is less than 1.
Unless the expected number of
offspring is less than or
equal to 1, then the probability
of dying out is in
fact equal to 1.
So that was just this graphical
picture, and that
does the whole thing, and if
you think about it for 10
minutes in a quiet room, I think
it will be obvious to
you, because there's no
rocket science here.
It's just a simple graphical
argument.
I have to think about it every
time I do it, because it
always looks implausible.
So it says the process can
explode if the expected number
of elements from each element
is larger than 1.
But it doesn't have
to explode.
There's an interesting theorem
that we'll talk about when we
start talking about
martingales.
And that is that the number of
elements in generation n
divided by the expected value of
y to the n-th power x sub n
divided by y-bar to
the n-th power.
This is something that
looks like it ought
to be kind of stable.
And it says that this approach
is a random variable.
Namely with probability 1, this
has some random value
that you can calculate.
With a certain probability,
this is equal to 0.
With a certain probability this
is some larger constant.
And it can be any old constant
at all with different
probabilities.
And you can sort of see
why this is happening.
Suppose you have this process.
Suppose y-bar is
bigger than 1.
Suppose it's equal
to 2 for example.
So the expected number of
offspring of each of these
elements is two, so the number
of offspring of 10 to the 6
elements is 2 times
10 to the sixth.
What this is doing is dividing
by that multiplying factor.
What's going to happen then is
after a certain amount of
time, you have so many elements,
and each one of them
is doing something
independently, so the number
of offspring in each generation
divided by an extra
y sub bar is almost constant.
And that's what this
theorem is saying.
So that after a while it says
the growth rate becomes fixed.
And that sort of obvious
intuitively.
That's enough for that.
Should've not been so talkative
about the earlier things.
But Markov processes turn out
to be pretty simple, given
what we know about
Markov chains.
There's not a lot of new things
to be learned here.
Just a few.
Accountable state Markov process
is most easily viewed
as a simple extension
of accountable
state Markov chain.
And along with each state in
the Markov chain, there's a
holding time.
So what happens in this process
is it goes along.
At a certain point there's
a state change.
The state change is according
to the Markov chain, and
amount of time that it takes
is an exponential random
variable which depends on
the state you are in.
So in some states you
move quickly.
In some states you
move slowly.
But the only thing that's going
on is you have a Markov
chain, and each state of the
Markov chain, there's some
rate which determines how long
it's going to take to get to
the next state change.
So that you can visualize what
the process looks like--
This is the state at times 0.
This determines some
holding time u1.
It also determines some
state at time 1.
The state you go to is
independent of how long it
takes you to get there.
This then determines the rate,
so it tells you the rate of
this exponential random
variable.
And we have this plus some
process leading off plus we
have this Markov process leading
along here, and for
each state of the Markov
process, you have
this holding time.
You will ask-- as I do every
time I look at this--
why did I make this
u1 instead of u0?
It's because of the
next slide.
OK?
Here's the next slide, which
shows what's going on.
So we start off at time 0, x
of 0 is in some state i.
We stay in state i until
some time u1, at
which the state changes.
The state change now
is some state j.
We stay in that same state j
until the next state change.
We stay in that state until the
next state change, and it
is since we want to make the
first state change time s of
one, we sort of have to make the
first interval between 0
on the state u1.
So these things are off
base from the u's.
And this is the way that a way
that a Markov process evolves.
You simply have what looks
like a Poisson process, a
variable rate, and the variable
rate is varying
according to the state of a
Markov chain every time you
have an arrival in the variable
rate Poisson process,
you change the rate according
to this Markov process.
So it's everything about Markov
chains, plus Poisson
processes all put together.
OK, I think I'll stop
there, and we will
continue next time.